did you always when you approached it
first it's just like hop in the studio
with this like played a couple beats for
you and you just started just started
freestyling did you actually try to
write something first the first the
first time you ever tried it I had
already had some [ __ ] right now I'd
already had some [ __ ] right now
I probably I wrote this probably like
two days after skinny had told me he was
gonna book me I was like [ __ ] I gotta be
prepared I don't want to just go in
there and say some [ __ ] so yeah man
literally got me in the studio I'm
[ __ ] spittin like [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] flexing on his hoes
like I'm pushing weight yeah like I
could I could hear them in the
background cuz we were like in a closet
like well I was in a closet and then
they was like in the bedroom right next
to the closet so so then somebody's
house it wasn't like a studio yeah like
a microphone yeah and [ __ ] mattresses
on the walls yeah so dude I'm hearing
everybody in the room I'm hearing them
do my headphones they're so loud you're
like yeah man I came in there I came in
there prepared a lot of my [ __ ] is a lot
of my [ __ ] is written I can freestyle
really good too but I like that I like
to relax and just write it down like
physically on paper like I can do the
notes I like I got hella raps in my
notes but I like that there's no better
feeling than just the way your [ __ ]
fingers glides across the paper when you
write some fire shiz yeah it makes you
think about it differently because
you're like there's something different
between just like tapping a screen and
then actually writing the words and the
way that it registers with your brain is
kind of like makes it sink in a little
bit more and helps you think about it a
little bit deeper yeah
what's dope is I have this book I got
from Barnes & Noble's a few months ago
it's called it's a book on like like
writer's block and like creative block
and [ __ ] like that
and they was talking about you know what
type of exercises you can do to
stimulate your
rain and [ __ ] and basically there's this
one exercise where they say just get a
piece of paper and just literally
whatever you're thinking of just write
it just write it out just continuous
thoughts don't stop thinking and don't
stop writing yeah I'm saying yeah that's
what makes you a better rapper or a
freestyle there at the same time you
know I'm so and usually it starts out
like the first 15 20 minutes of writing
just is just [ __ ] nothing
meaningless [ __ ] then eventually it just
gets into something that's good and has
some meat to it yeah my favorite thing
about you is that you don't take your
tell you don't take yourself too
seriously you talk about whatever
whatever the [ __ ] you want NASCAR Joe
Dirt Carol Baskin crow files all the
[ __ ] that we love oh my god dude I'm so
influenced by so much stuff man I feel
like and I feel like that's what makes
me so relatable because I I rap about
Yugi I rap about you know I'm saying I
tweet I tweet all day long about
[ __ ] but it's so relatable you know
I'm saying like oh my god I can't think
of anything off the top of my head but
like I'll tweet like I'll tweet like
like but I want to be as transparent
what my fans as possible to where they
feel like you know I'm saying like I'm
normal
you know I'm saying like there's nothing
worse than like an artist you know
feeling you know you like artists feel
like they're untouchable or like they
like just you know I'm saying [ __ ] that
man like yeah I want artists I want my
fans to feel like you know I'm saying
they can like have a beer with me in a
gear one of them yeah that you're
building a community you know you're not
like building a kingdom where it's just
like this is all about me and you're
here for me this is for us right right
dude cuz like when I win my fans win and
and I think them all the time you know
I'm saying it's just reassurance like
you guys are the best
cuz [ __ ] I could be working the
nine-to-five right now man like grateful
everyday everyday I wake up I'm like
hang on God working down to five we said
yeah we should get rough I'm like damn
man like that's cuz really when I was
younger doing this [ __ ] I was like yo
like can I make this a career you know
saying cuz when I first started I was I
was juggling the job and the rap [ __ ]
you know I'm saying so there's a thing
that a lot of people go through when
they first start is like damn like when
do I like quit my job and fully pursue
this and there's a lot of anxiety and
fear you know I said behind that like oh
like but I'm not making enough money
doing the music [ __ ] to quit the job you
know sin trading dreams for securities
yeah man but it's uh it's tough man but
once you set on that bro you good my
advice to any upcoming artist man follow
that [ __ ] there's never a good time to
quit your job yes yeah no you just gotta
[ __ ] do it man cuz really like what
what when I knew exactly when I wanted
to quit dude it was my first label
meeting so I had a meeting with a label
in New York and I took like a week off
of work and me and Pablo have went out
to New York and uh where were you
working norstrom right okay nice turn
right man but uh we went to New York we
was out there for like a week came back
you know and and I was like damn yo like
I can't do this like I was just in New
York like at a label meeting like I
can't like it was just like it kind of
kind of did son to my ego in a way
anyway it was like damn like I'm here
getting bossed around you know like they
don't know that I was just up there like
doing doing this and they're like I
don't know if fed in today you know the
hunger who knows like you know I can't
do this no more
so you came back I came I turned in the
keys I came back with just a whole new
confidence man like
[ __ ] this job and I'm doing this music
[ __ ] like yeah and and you know all the
A&R is at the office you know sin and
just seeing like just everybody else
that was signed to this label and just
shaking all these hands and it was so
like cuz that was my first time seeing
any of that [ __ ] it was like yo like
this was happening right now alright
like I can do this you know oh yeah
what is silly rabbit what is this what
is what is this stuff you got here
alright so silly rabbit the the name
came from a lyric to one of my songs
jelly and jelly I had said silly rabbit
you can't have it I got carried to my -
mmm so we just took that lyric and was
like yo this would be a pretty good idea
to turn this into a beer and put trick
cereal in the beer you know say like at
first it just sounded so crazy but I was
like you know what this is gonna be a
really good idea cuz you know one thing
what alcohol is like you know not
everybody likes to drink beer like yeah
you know there's a lot of people that
don't like to taste the beer you could
definitely make some weed called silly
rabbit - right smoked one joint turn
your silly but yeah like wait with this
it was kind of like you know like wanted
to make some [ __ ] that you know anybody
could drink you know I'm saying not
necessarily just a beer like a pills in
there like people don't like that
gritty bitter you know piss yeah I put
tastes you don't says so but it's silly
rabbit was like all right like this
tastes like juice like it literally
tastes like juice you know it looks
delicious like yeah that's a milk after
you eat some yeah double its it's really
good bro it's really like honestly it
creeps up on you like that because it's
a tall boy - who do you brew this with
it's a 5.5% so this is yes so like a Bud
Light is like 4.3 4.1 or so
but it's brewed with Hidden Springs
Hidden Springs brewery they're out in
Tampa right yeah yeah they're uh right
before you get to downtown um they're
right next to a YMCA you know a oriental
market okay yeah that's sick so this is
just like one of the many things that
you have four former trite
you got the whole merch Empire online
yeah man I got I got condoms I got the
hand sanitizer and those are the big
baby come bags right yeah do come bags
bro that was always that was always like
an inside joke yeah it was all it was
always like an inside joke how did that
joke come to come to live dude like okay
so I would see fans be like how is his
name pretty now it's like cuz come back
on Twitter on my Twitter handle it's all
like all caps all big baby scumbags so
it's like you know I'm saying that s
right there could get kind of you don't
say take it or leave it up to you you
don't know where that s really goes it
was always like an inside joke on
Twitter and Instagram like damn like is
it babies come back so you know that was
kind of just like a that was honestly
that was like a troll for like my fans
cuz at first I wasn't gonna put those
out you know I just do that idea out
there one day and I was like you know
what I might actually make some condoms
yeah and yeah not they did really good
what do you take a lot of suggestions
from people on Twitter to make stuff uh
or on social media in general you
interact with them and they like give
you ideas that you kind of run with yeah
yeah I try I try to I try to be a little
more authentic though yeah cuz like fans
bro fans are quick to be like oh yeah I
gave you that idea give me credit like
you know I'm saying so yeah and I try I
try not to feed into like fans ideas
like that you know I'm saying unless
it's like a really good one cuz yo like
there's been a bunch of [ __ ] that I've
came out with or like do like certain
lines like certain lyrics bro
that I've had in my songs and like a
fans would be like oh you stole that
from my song that I made a week ago even
though your song is like months old
useless so yeah dude I try not to like
as far as ideas like either I don't
really you know take them from from from
from people suggesting though like I
just I try to come up me and my team me
Pablo
my DJ DJ Chuck Louis gum Sonny Fritz you
know I'll talk amongst them and be like
yellow like what you think about this or
what you think about this you know I'm
saying and if the homies [ __ ] with it I
know everybody else gonna [ __ ] what he
says
[Laughter]